[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi.
And welcome to Episode Number
31 of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with Mark
Mandel, my colleague.
How are you doing, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing well, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm pretty well.
I'm very happy
with the interview
we're going to be having today
with one of our colleagues
working here in the San
Francisco office, Eli Bixby.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's going to be a really
interesting discussion
on TensorFlow.
We're going to go
quite deep on it.
I think it's going to be fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You're going to learn about,
among other things, why
is it called TensorFlow.
That I didn't know, actually.
MARK MANDEL: No.
No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
learned something today.
And after that we're
going to be discussing--
we're going to be
talking about big data,
but not how to process it, but
how to upload really big data.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
What do you do when
you have lots of data
that you want to
give to Google Cloud?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So we're going to be talking
about a couple of options
that we have available
for you if you
have-- I don't know-- terabytes
or petabytes or whatever.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Lots and lots of
data but first we've
got our cool thing of the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And it is very cool this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So we literally just
as we were recording
this announced the Google Cloud
Platform Education Grants.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Or for those
less Australian-- grants.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: This is a
pretty cool endeavor.
I'm very excited about it.
Currently it only applies
to the United States,
but we're hoping to expand
it internationally soon, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Soon.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Soon.
But basically, yeah,
if you're looking
to use Google Cloud Platform in
your educational institution,
and you want to have
free Cloud Credits-- say
that three times quickly-- free
Cloud Credits for your students
to be able to use the
resources at Google Cloud,
we now offer the ability
to apply for that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And it is very cool,
because so far we've
been doing it for
some specific cases.
And actually, we have
a link to the blog post
where we announced the
educational program.
But one of the links is
actually Cloud for Cancer,
and I was reading about it.
I thought it was very cool.
It was basically like
a neural network.
And if you don't know what a
neural network is, don't worry.
We're going to be talking
about it in a minute.
But basically a
neural network that
allows doctors to upload
the properties of a melanoma
and detect if it's
malignant or not.
So basically it's trying
to provide very good, very
high-quality information.
I think that they
mention they have
like 99.9% accuracy for doctors
all around the world, which
is pretty awesome.
And it runs for
free on App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: There's a
couple of other things
I quite like about this.
One-- it's not just
hey, here's some stuff.
Do with it as you will.
There is also documentation
for students and teachers
that's provided.
So there's some extra resources
you have to help teach this
to the students.
As well as that, faculty
sponsors of technology focus
groups, such as
Women Techmakers,
Google Developer Groups,
et cetera, et cetera,
are also able to apply as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
No.
It is pretty awesome.
And for those that don't
have access to it yet,
don't forget that if you
want to give it a try,
there's also the
free trial program.
So you have-- I think
it's three months.
During three months you have--
MARK MANDEL: 60
days, $300, I think
was the last time
I looked at it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah. $300, 60 days,
which is not three months.
It is two months.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But yeah.
Check it out.
And if you're interested, we'll
have a link on the show notes.
So you can apply
directly and maybe
be one of the lucky first
ones to get our grants.
MARK MANDEL: That'd be great.
Awesome.
Well, why don't we go
have a chat with Eli
and talk about TensorFlow?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Let's start with him.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
Today we are joined
by Eli Bixby.
He's happily agreed to
grace us with his presence.
How are you doing today, Eli?
ELI BIXBY: I'm doing great.
MARK MANDEL: Eli,
why don't you tell us
a little bit about who you are
and what you do here at Google?
ELI BIXBY: Great.
So I'm a developer programs
engineer at Google.
I work on Google Cloud Platform
and specifically the big data
and machine learning offerings.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So what is a developer programs
engineer in one sentence?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
That's a hard task.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We could do
an episode on that one day.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So we write code to teach
users how to use the platform.
So this code may end
up in blog posts,
in tutorials and workshops, or
it may end up on the website.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we have you here
today because we
wanted to discuss a little
bit about TensorFlow.
But before we start
talking about TensorFlow,
for all the audience that
have never done any machine
learning, what is-- TensorFlow
I've heard is neural networks.
What is a neural network?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So TensorFlow is mainly
for neural networks.
A neural network
in general is-- you
can think of it sort of like
it's a directed graph where
the nodes are simply
like arithmetic
activations of their inputs.
So there are some
nodes upstream.
They feed into a
downstream node.
And the node has a single output
based on the upstream nodes.
And it was sort of
discovered a long time ago,
like in the '70s, that
you could use these.
And you could use back
propagation, which basically
says, I want the top layer of
nodes to have this certain--
or I want the
output layer to have
a certain output when the top
layer has a certain input.
And you can use back propagation
to adjust the function
that each node operates on to
line up with these outputs,
and that you can model
very complex functions
with many layers
of neural networks.
MARK MANDEL: Where did
this idea come from?
Do you know any of the history
of how it sort of came about?
ELI BIXBY: I'm not sure.
I think it was
actually originally
sort of a theoretical
attempt to model
like human cognition, which
is why it's neural networks.
I'm not sure that that
is part of its usage now.
But I think that's where
the name came from.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So just to try to
understand a bit better what
neural networks are-- basically
at the end of the day what you
have is a bunch of
nodes, and every node
is like a function
where you get bunch
of parameters and an output?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
And the nodes are actually
really a helpful abstraction
for us to think about it.
But it's actually TensorFlow
is named TensorFlow
because its tensor is
flowing along a graph.
And really you think
of it as the layers
are single entities that are
tensor transformations from one
to the next layer.
And so often we talk about
layers and the activation
function of a layer
of the tensor graph
rather than individual nodes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So now we know what TensorFlow
comes from-- the name.
Why is TensorFlow a thing?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So TensorFlow is the successor
to Google's previous machine
learning framework.
And really the reason
it's open source
is we believe that there is
going to be a lot of innovation
in machine learning.
And we think it's
important for these tools
to sort of be
standardized and for work
to be shared among the
machine learning community.
And so having a common
framework for expressing machine
learning algorithms
is really important.
So previously you'd see papers,
and you'd see people kind of
informally describe
the algorithm
that they were writing about.
But now you can actually
publish the code.
And it's another step towards
reproducible research.
It allows people to
collaborate more easily--
all the great things we
love about open source.
MARK MANDEL: So
you touched on it
a little bit when you started
talking about tensors flowing
through a graph, but can we
break that down even further?
What's a tensor?
How does this work?
Give us sort of like a
base level understanding.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So mathematicians are going to
hate me for this definition,
but a tensor is a
multi-dimensional matrix.
So you think of a vector as
just a list of numbers, right?
So like an array in
Python and a matrix
then is a list of
lists of numbers.
And so a tensor is-- a vector
is a one-dimensional tensor.
A matrix is a
two-dimensional tensor.
And then a matrix of vectors
is a three-dimensional tensor.
And you can expand that,
and you get this concept
of shape, which is a
vector that represents
the shape of a tensor.
And so for the users who
have used NumPy before,
this should be a very
familiar concept.
TensorFlow actually follows
the exact same syntax
that NumPy does for
defining these things.
MARK MANDEL: And so how
does that correlate into how
we do machine learning?
Why is that important?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So it's really important in
particular for deep learning,
because a lot of
these algorithms
can be thought of as a series
of tensor computations.
And there's a lot
of optimization.
You can also do restricting
the data that's flowing along
your graph to tensors.
So if you compare it with
something like Apache Beam
or Spark, where there's
sort of arbitrary
data flowing along
your computation graph,
and you can define
your own serialization
and deserialization.
TensorFlow, by contrast,
is all in memory
and calls out to very fast C
implementations of these tensor
operations.
And obviously that allows you
to make-- like plug into CUDA
and use GPUs really easily.
So the restricting it to tensors
gets us a lot of functionality.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
So you actually mention
GPUs, because I'm
assuming that GPUs
are better suited
for this kind of computations.
But we also announced
this other thing-- TPUs.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So the strength of GPUs
actually ties a lot
into why we're seeing a
resurgence in neural networks.
The techniques have been
around for a long time.
And now we have this
commodity hardware
that's just fantastic
for neural networks.
And we're seeing neural
networks be extremely useful
in all of these applications.
And so we're seeing
a huge growth.
And we're actually
getting to the point
where it makes sense to actually
have ASICs for TensorFlow.
So that's what a TPU is.
MARK MANDEL: What's an ASIC?
ELI BIXBY: An ASIC is--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
ELI BIXBY: I think the acronym
is Application Specific
Integrated Chip.
So it's a custom
piece of hardware
that-- and the optimization
you're looking for,
because we have these big
data centers, the optimization
you're looking for is
performance per watt.
Right?
So they allow you to
do the operations that
are common in machine
learning at a lower power.
And that means you get
a higher throughput,
because you can run
a lot more of them
for the same amount
of electricity.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So it sounds like TensorFlow
is kind of a complicated
and pretty complex framework.
Does that mean that
to get started with it
I need to understand what
tensors and monads are?
ELI BIXBY: No.
So the actual goal
is that developers
can start writing machine
learning algorithms
and start incorporating
machine learning easily
into their code, and that's
a huge goal of TensorFlow.
So TensorFlow itself, there's
a lot you can do with it.
You can write custom operations.
You can fiddle around
with the internals.
But we try to
provide a high level
interface for people who don't
necessarily want to do that.
And we're actually looking
at building more layers
on top of TensorFlow to make
it easier for developers
to get started with it.
So I think it's
publicly available.
But I think it's like whatever
the open source version
of alpha would be considered.
We have a package called
Wide and Deep, which
provides a higher level
abstraction on top
of TensorFlow that allows you
to say, I have sparse features.
Learn these sparse features.
Or like I have dense features.
Learn these dense features.
And so it's very--
all you really
have to know about is
what your data looks like.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Cool.
So how do I know if
TensorFlow is good for me?
What are the typical use
cases where the answer
is like, oh, yeah, TensorFlow.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So we hope to expand it to a lot
of different machine learning
applications.
I think in particular if
you have a problem that's
well-suited to deep
learning, TensorFlow
is a great solution for you.
Again, deep learning
algorithms, they
require a huge amount
of data to train,
more so than many other
machine learning algorithms.
So you need to have that
at least somewhat available
to you.
MARK MANDEL: What's
a good heuristic
for a large amount of data?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
I think sort of the ballpark
lower level is maybe
like 100,000.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
ELI BIXBY: Labeled is
common, for example,
for text-- text or image.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you mentioned this label.
Does that mean that your
data needs to be labeled?
And actually, what does
it mean to be labeled?
And do you need that?
ELI BIXBY: So we
commonly break down usage
of deep learning into two
different parts-- training
and inference.
And so training is running
this TensorFlow graph
on your label data and using it
to generate the proper weights.
And then inferences-- you
have this unlabeled data where
you want to predict the label.
And so you're giving that to
the trained TensorFlow graph,
and it's spinning out a
probability for the label.
MARK MANDEL: So
when you say label,
it's kind of like, all right,
so I've got a bunch of data
wherein-- I don't know.
Pick an example.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
have a bunch of emails,
and you need to know
if it's spam or not.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That works.
That's great.
So you know whether it's spam.
And so you can feed that
through the system and be like,
yes, these are spam.
These aren't.
And it can be like, yay!
Now I'm learning.
And then at the end when
you do your inference,
you can hand it an email and
it will tell you whether or not
it's spam to, I guess,
some degree of certainty.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
Email's a perfect
example, because then you
have a bunch of users
essentially providing you
with labels.
You know, they click the
Report Spam button and bam!
You have another
labeled piece of data.
And there's increasing
levels of sophistication.
But that's sort of the basics
is like, I have this label.
I want to predict the
label of something else.
So maybe you have like
a confidence cut-off.
And you're like,
oh, my model is not
very confident about
this piece of spam,
so I'm going to
surface it to the user.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You were mentioning
something before which
I thought it was very cool.
It was the one with
Reddit subreddits.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So we gave a talk
at OSCON and PyCon
where we made a little
example algorithm
based on some colleague's
work with text classification.
And we used it to classify
Reddit post titles
by subreddit.
And we got, I think, a
pretty good accuracy.
Not state of the art, but
I think it was mid-90's.
And yeah, these are topics
that are very well-suited,
because there are large
data sets available.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So let's talk
about that specific example.
How does it look for a
developer to do that?
I imagine they
have all the titles
and what subreddit
they belong to.
What is the next step?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So there's going to be like
a pre-processing setup.
And we frequently use Apache
Beam to preprocess our data.
And so then once
you have your data
in sort of this
nice vector format,
you can go and grab and try
to adapt for your use case
one of the many open sources.
There are many models
already out there.
So frequently you'll try to
figure out-- what category
does my problem fit into?
OK, it's a text
classification problem.
Oh, great.
Someone's already written a
text classification model.
And then you'll try training
that model on your data
with your preprocessed data.
And then you'll do some
testing and some validation
and say, OK.
This worked.
This didn't work.
Let me tinker around with
the model a little bit
until you get sort of an
accuracy you're happy with.
MARK MANDEL: Let's sort of
take even a further step back.
OK.
So you say model.
What does that input
and output look like?
What's a model?
How does that work together?
ELI BIXBY: So
TensorFlow graphs are
defined with this Python code.
So TensorFlow is like
a Python Package.
You write sort of operations.
And an operation
will typically have
arguments that are previous
operations you've defined.
So in this way you're defining
like a directed graph.
So there's two parts.
There's the graph definition.
And then there's
the training step
where you're running through
basically a loop saying, OK.
Grab a batch of
my training data.
Run it through the graph.
It'll calculate gradients.
It will update the
operations on each node,
like you were talking about.
And then do that
until we're satisfied
with whatever accuracy
we're getting,
or whatever loss we're getting.
Whatever function we've
decided is our metric.
And then that will
constitute a model.
And then there are also lots
of sort of ops to your packages
that we've open sourced.
So for example,
TensorFlow serving
allows you to serve
models who do inference.
That's the other half.
So you'll export a model, which
is exporting these weights
and this graph to a file.
And then TensorFlow Serving
can load it for you,
and then provide you an
API-- a gRPC API-- where
you can call it with a vector.
And it'll return back
the output vector
that you'd expect,
maybe the labels.
MARK MANDEL: So if I was taking
say, like a Reddit title,
and I'm going to convert
that into like a vector.
What does that vector look like?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So I talked a little bit before,
without explaining myself,
about sparse data
and dense data.
So like Reddit,
maybe a Reddit title
is a list of vectors
where each vector is
your entire vocabulary.
So maybe like 40,000 words
in the English language
or whatever.
And there's a 1 somewhere
in there corresponding
to the word.
Like cat is a 1.
And maybe cat is like
the 30,250th word.
So like the 30,250th index
in your vector is a 1.
And everything else is 0's.
So that's sparse data.
Frequently in deep learning
we'll do embeddings.
So we'll try to learn denser
representations of data,
because the neural nets
tend to handle these denser
representations better.
And this is something we
talked about in our workshop,
words actually lend
themselves very
well to this dense embedding.
So you may actually
already have a model.
So there may be-- if
you look at-- so we open
sourced SyntaxNet,
for example, which
is a piece of Google's natural
language processing written
in TensorFlow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wasn't
it called Parsey McFarsi?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So there's a subtle
difference here.
We open sourced two things.
We open sourced SyntaxNet,
which is the graph definition.
And then we open
sourced a trained model.
So including the weights
and all the trained bits,
called Parsey
McParseface, which was
trained on a subset of
the data that we have.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
ELI BIXBY: And so if
you look at SyntaxNet,
it's actually a bunch
of trained pieces,
a bunch of different neural
nets that feed into each other.
So there's this sense
of composability, which
brings me back to embedding.
So you may have a model that
somebody else has already
written for generating
word embeddings where you
feed in your one hot vector.
And it gives you back a denser
representation of words.
So maybe what you're
learning is a mapping
from these word embeddings
to subreddit classification.
And so that's part of what we
hope to spur by this ecosystem
is like this sense of
composability and other people
taking their models
and using them
as pieces of their own
models, and then providing
those models as pieces
for other people
to use, and just sort of
building this whole ecosystem.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we've been talking about
models and that basically
you're going to be training
some neural network where
you create that model.
And then that model is a
valuable piece of information
that you can use.
How big is a model?
ELI BIXBY: Oh, man.
I think it varies a huge amount.
I'm not even sure how well
I can give a ballpark.
I think it depends a huge
amount on the variables,
like the size.
Like if we had a
vocabulary of 50 words,
and we were doing-- or not
a vocabulary of 50 words.
If we were doing an embedding
in like a vector of 50 link,
that's going to be a much
smaller file than an embedding
with a vector of 100 link.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Are we
talking gigabytes here?
Terabytes?
ELI BIXBY: I think we
can be talking gigabytes.
Smaller models, I think,
may be under that.
But definitely I think
probably not a terabyte.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So OK.
So it's going to be--
ELI BIXBY: On the
order of gigabytes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Cool.
MARK MANDEL: So if I want to sit
down, and I'm like, all right.
This thing sounds super cool,
sounds super interesting.
How would I get started
with TensorFlow?
Where is a good place to start?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
So TensorFlow.org has a
bunch of great tutorials
that the Brain
Team has provided.
MNIST is kind of the
Hello World of TensorFlow.
So that's this problem
that's been around
for a long time where you
have handwritten digits,
and you want to classify
them to the correct number.
And so I think that's sort of
the first place to get started.
And there's an
MNIST for beginners.
And there's an MNIST
for ML experts.
So you know, it'll walk
you through what is MNIST.
Why is it important?
Here's a little bit of
the math behind sort
of the state-of-the-art
MNIST algorithms,
if you're a beginner.
And if not, it will be just
like, here's TensorFlow.
And here's how it corresponds
to the MNIST algorithm
that you're familiar with.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Also, since you
mentioned that workshop
that you gave at
OSCON and PyCon.
That was like three
hours, and it is online.
Could you recommend
that as an entry point
to someone that has
never done TensorFlow?
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
We tried to make it
pretty accessible.
I think even three
hours, it's kind of
hard to fit in a
comprehensive intro.
And so I think it's
a little squashed.
But certainly you
should check that out.
And even if it's just
for the resource slides,
we have a lot of
resource slides in there
to sort of get you
started on your own.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
That sounds very interesting.
We're kind of
running out of time.
Is there anything else
that you would like
to mention before we finish?
ELI BIXBY: Not off
the top of my head.
Definitely check out TensorFlow.
It's worth a look.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: One
last question, actually.
What is the best use case
of TensorFlow, the most fun
usage of TensorFlow
you have ever seen?
ELI BIXBY: So I love DCGANs
which is some crazy acronym.
But Generative Adversarial
Network is the last bit.
So it's actually two
neural nets that are
competing against each other.
One of them is
trying to classify
the output of the first
one and your training data.
And the other one is trying to
generate from noise things that
look like your training data.
And so you're training
this neural network
to generate-- to trick
this other neural network,
basically.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, wow.
ELI BIXBY: And so
there's a bunch
of hilarious
pictures in the paper
and in the git hub of
like, generated bedrooms.
And they're like
uncanny valley bedrooms.
They're things that look
almost like bedrooms,
but there is something
wrong about them.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
ELI BIXBY: And there's
generated faces.
And they're like
uncanny valley faces.
It's like they're almost faces.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
We're going to
add a link to that
and definitely check it out.
It sounds very fun.
ELI BIXBY: Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Eli, thank you
so much for joining us today.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
ELI BIXBY: Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
So thank you to Eli for such
an interesting conversation.
Before we move to
the next topic,
I wanted to add a
couple of corrections
that he actually gave as
soon as we stopped recording.
One of them-- we asked him
how big TensorFlow models are,
and he said probably
around gigabytes.
And it turns out it's
more like megabytes.
And he said that the
problem is that he's not
used to counting
that low anymore,
since he works at Google.
Kind of humble, right?
But yeah, it's
actually megabytes.
So you can consider sending
them to your mobile phone
or having them as part of your
app, which is pretty cool.
And then something that
is not a correction,
but I wanted to add anyway.
He mentioned Apache
Beam, which is actually
something you can run on
Google Cloud Platform,
on Google Cloud Dataflow, and
also TensorFlow you can run it.
Or you'll be able
to run it soon,
because it's limited preview
for now on Google Cloud ML.
ML stands for Machine
Learning, obviously.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So let's go to the
question of the week.
And I think it comes from-- you
got the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: I did get
the question of the week.
It was from some people I
was chatting with this week.
And they were talking
about how-- OK.
Say you have 10 terabytes, 15
terabytes, 20 terabytes of data
sort of lying around, maybe on
a nest, maybe on a hard drive,
maybe running on-prem,
something like that.
And you want to move everything
over to Google Cloud Platform.
And you're like,
this is going to take
me a really long
time to upload if I
have to do it over the wire.
So what do I do?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
encode it into XML.
And then you-- no.
No, no, no.
So I mean, there's
one option, which
is you can use gsutil
to start sending
that file through the network.
And that's going to
take a very long time.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Weeks, months.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Like long, long, long time.
So instead of doing that,
there's a couple options.
And one of them was the
one that you mentioned.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So we have a couple of
partners, one of which
is Iron Mountain for US areas.
And the other one is Prime Focus
Technologies for EMEA and APAC.
Pretty much is-- yeah.
You can take a hard
drive, bundle it up,
stick it on a courier
like FedEx or UPS,
and send it directly to them.
And they'll load it up
for you quick smart.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that is actually-- yeah.
I think that Eli mentioned
that, that there's
no wider then-- no.
How do you say it?
MARK MANDEL: What?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
band is bandwidth.
There you go.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
no connection with higher
bandwidth than the mail.
Like post mail.
You just send it,
and we receive it.
Well, our partners
receive it and upload it.
And they appear directly
onto Google Cloud Storage.
So that is probably one
of the fastest options.
But I wanted to
add one more, which
is what if you really want
to make this very fast
and all the time?
It's not that you're sending--
you have 10 terabytes,
and you have to send them once.
But it's you keep on generating
10 terabytes per day,
and you want to send that as
soon as possible onto Google
Cloud.
And there's a solution for that.
It's what we call Google
Cloud Interconnect.
And basically what you
get is rather than having
public internet connection
from your data center to ours,
you're going to get very
good quality connection.
I think they use the term
enterprise grade, which I'm not
really sure what that means.
But I'm assuming
it's really fast.
And it connects directly
from your data center
to Google's network edge.
MARK MANDEL: So this would be if
you had a sort of on-prem cloud
mixup type deal.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I could imagine something like
that where for instance, you're
doing something like very, very
intense data, like big data.
And you're generating
a huge amount of data,
and you want to send it directly
to Big Query or something
like that.
And in that case, if you have
such a huge amount of data,
you need to send it somehow and
maybe sending disks via mail
is not good enough.
So in that case you can go
through Cloud Interconnect.
The pricing for
it-- it's actually
something that
depends on the cases.
So you need to
contact a provider.
I guess it depends on how
far away you live from a data
center and stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: No.
That sounds really cool.
Maybe you have
requirements that mean
you have to be on-prem
for various things,
like your app has to be there.
But you want to use
their big data tools,
and you want to send
that data through.
That sounds really good.
That's cool.
The whole sending of hard
drives through UPS or FedEx
could be like the one time thing
you do if you're moving over
to the cloud, if you're
on-prem and you want
to make that shift as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Cool.
Well, I think we're pretty
much done with the episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
I'm curious about what
you're going to be up to
next week or after that.
MARK MANDEL: So I am
staying in San Francisco
for the next week and a half.
But I will be off
to New York after
that for a panel at
a play crafting event
we'll be holding in
the New York offices.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: So that
will be lots of fun.
And then after that
I'm hanging around
in San Francisco for a while.
So I think I'm pretty good.
What are you up to?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So next week
I'm going to Los Angeles again.
This time I'm flying,
so it should be faster.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
And I'm going to be giving a
talk at-- I think the name is
Los Angeles Gophers Meetup.
It's the Go Meetup in LA.
So basically it's
going to be kind
of my rehearsal for GopherCon.
Then in the second
week of July, I'll
be at GopherCon in
Denver, Colorado.
MARK MANDEL: That'll be fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's pretty much it.
And then after that, I
think, holidays are deserved.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds pretty good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Well, Francesc,
thank you once more
for joining me for this
weekly episode of the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you very much, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you very
much to all our listeners
for paying attention once more.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And talk to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]